[Music]
on this Sunday night a new year and the
return of an old travel restriction the
upcoming requirement for some people
arriving in Canada a policy like this
will not impact the covet trajectory why
doctors have their doubts rocket plan
North Korea is expanding nuclear
strategy and the debate over how the
South should respond
and another Pointer Sister forever
silenced
the death of singer Anita Poynter
[Applause]
global national with Farah Nasser
reporting tonight Sonya sungar
good evening and happy New Year as we
begin 2023 covid-19 is once again
prompting changes to travel Canada is
joining a growing list of countries
requiring a negative test from some air
passengers on canadian-bound flights but
as Sean O'Shea reports some experts say
it will do little to stop the spread of
potential new variants
Sonia Canada ended mandatory testing for
travelers coming into this country by
air last April but starting later this
week testing is back but only for some
Travelers
Canadian airports are busy places this
holiday season Flyers need patience but
they don't require kova 19 testing
leaving the country or coming home a
mandatory requirement just a short while
ago but that's changing again for
travelers coming from mainland China
Hong Kong and Macau I think it's just
like a matter of looking at the numbers
right now the government might just
think that like in China it's really
high numbers covid-19 case counts in
those countries are causing concern
around the world South Korea Spain
France the UK and the United States are
all requiring negative covid-19 tests
from those passengers on Saturday Health
Canada said in response to the surge of
kova 19 and the People's Republic of
China and given the limited
epidemiological and viral genomic
sequence data available on those cases
the government of Canada is putting in
place certain temporary health measures
for air Travelers entering Canada from
China we have lots of Copa here and
that's not going to have a meaningful
impact the real issue is what are we
what are we actually trying to
accomplish with a policy like that this
man's father is returning on a flight
from Hong Kong the numbers look pretty
high over there so I guess they're just
being cautious I don't think it's like
any form of racism or anything this man
just arrived from Hong Kong do you think
it's reasonable for Canada to require
people to be tested it's reasonable
totally yeah everyone is safe it's okay
Travelers will have to show a negative
test taken within the last two days or
if they tested positive more than 10
days earlier be able to document to the
airline that they've recovered more
paperwork but some experts say at this
point of the pandemic the rules will
likely be ineffective we know that very
focused and targeted travel measures
especially in the context of covid-19
those don't have any significance uh
outcomes in terms of preventing the
importation of variants of concern the
federal government says the testing
requirement is temporary and will be
reevaluated in 30 days the new rules
take effect on Thursday Sonya all right
thanks very much Sean in the U.S big
changes are coming to Congress this week
the Republicans are set to regain
control of the House of Representatives
Jennifer Johnson looks at the bills and
the investigations the party is pushing
for
2023 will ring in a new and tumultuous
year for congress as Republicans Take
Over Control of the house with Democrats
still running the Senate the GOP is
already planning to introduce
controversial bills cracking down on
border crossings and limiting access to
abortions we have strong Republican
leadership ready to hit the ground
running ready to go on January 3rd when
we take back the House Majority those
bills are considered Dead on Arrival and
the democratic-controlled Senate
continued funding for Ukraine in its
fight against Russia's brutal invasion
is also on The Hit List can't keep up
with it I mean and we're just flushing
money out and we don't know where it's
going but before the battles begin and
any member can be sworn into the new
Congress the GOP has to elect a house
Speaker we have fired Nancy Pelosi
former house Speaker Kevin McCarthy
wants his old job back but doesn't have
enough votes now to get elected we want
new leadership we want fresh faces and
new ideas this bill summer pushing
Congressman Jim Jordan for the job
Jordan will become the new house
Judiciary Committee chair and his
promising investigations into Hunter
Biden's overseas business dealings and
whether those had any foreign influence
over his father President Joe Biden
we're committed to getting to the truth
the facts we think that's what the
American people are entitled to the GOP
striking back after the Democrats
multiple investigations of former
president Donald Trump who may face
Federal criminal charges for his role in
the January 6 Capital Riot I think it's
a disgrace what's happened with the FBI
and with the weapon organization of
Justice there's never been anything like
this and it is disgraceful many predict
there will be more fighting than bills
getting passed until the next election
in 2024.
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
a political battle over immigration is
also boiling over in the U.S the Biden
Administration wants to end title 42
former president Trump's controversial
policy which allows border authorities
to expel migrants without giving them a
chance to seek Asylum Reggie cicchini
reports
the barbed wires and armed guards are an
uninviting first glimpse of a country so
many are desperate to enter but the
endless line of migrants are assigned to
those just arriving the journey isn't
over
this feels like a bucket of cold water
but we don't know what to do this
Venezuelan migrant says she's referring
to a decision by the U.S Supreme Court
to allow title 42 to remain in place
it's a public health policy implemented
by former president Donald Trump in 2020
to control the spread of covid-19 but it
allows border officials to expel
migrants and Asylum Seekers it has
functioned as an immigration control
measure that is not what the law is
supposed to be doing Republicans argued
Federal resources didn't exist to lift
title 42 seeing the plan as a way to
stem a steady flow of immigrants but
even under the policy undocumented
Crossings were up by more than 800 000
in 2022. it is a situation where people
are fleeing very difficult and
deteriorating living circumstances for
those who do manage to cross freedoms
are often still Out Of Reach without
paperwork many can't access shelters and
wind up huddled on streets others have
been used in political stunts Bust or
flown to democrat-led States no one
wants that for their community no one
wants that for the people that are out
in the streets enforcing immigration
policies and and who can be here or not
that that's that truly is a federal
issue bipartisan reform failed under a
Democrat majority and a looming
Republican House Majority intends to
focus on border security instead what we
really need is for Congress to act and
create other ways for people to come to
the country for work purposes and other
needs that we have in our economy a
Supreme Court decision is expected by
June 2023 extending the uncertainty for
both migrants and Border towns Reggie
Kinney Global News Washington
ukrainians woke up to a grim 2023 after
fresh missile attacks across the country
[Music]
residents in Kiev cheered from their
balconies as air defenses shot down
Russian missiles and drones targeting
the capital at least three people were
killed during Russia's New Year's Eve
assault
and there's anxiety over what North
Korea could be doing with its missiles
leader Kim Jong-un says he wants to
develop a new intercontinental ballistic
missile system to beef up his country's
nuclear Arsenal Redmond Shannon explains
what's behind the expansion and the
pressure South Korea is facing
a typical adoring welcome for North
Korean leader Kim Jong-un nut New Year's
Eve celebrations the spectacular show
came on a day when North Korea unveiled
what it called new super large rocket
missile launchers and after it fired
three more missiles into the Sea of
Japan
South Korea's military called the test a
grave provocation 2022 was a record year
for North Korean missile tests with
around three times as Manny launches as
the previous record in 2017 and it looks
to be much the same for 2023
a New Year's Day test was followed by an
announcement on state TV saying North
Korea needs to greatly increase its
nuclear Arsenal and that it must develop
another intercontinental ballistic
missile system to counter threats from
the United States and South Korea
Japanese officials say this November
test indicated North Korea could hit
anywhere in the continental United
States with a nuclear warhead
in October a North Korean missile flew
over Northern Japan triggering alarms as
I know prime minister fumio kushida is
now looking to double its defense
spending by 2027 and there is a growing
debate in South Korea about whether it
should develop its own nuclear weapons
this past week South Korea's president
Yun Suk Yul said his country's military
Readiness is greatly lacking after it
failed to shoot down five North Korean
drones that flew into Southern airspace
in recent years Donald Trump's attempt
to engage closely with Kim came to
nothing and sanctions have had little
effect either it appears as though North
Korea will continue to be a growing
headache for East Asia and the rest of
the world Redmond Shannon Global News
London
Pope Francis prayed for Peace during a
special New Year's Day Mass
the pontiff offered greetings to
thousands gathered in Saint Peter's
Square he also prayed for Pope Emeritus
Benedict's passage to Heaven a day after
he died Benedict Will lion stayed at
Saint Peter's Basilica starting tomorrow
thousands are expected to file past his
coffin in three days of viewing
Canada's MPS had plenty on their plates
this year coming up our Ottawa Bureau
looks back at politics in 2022.
2022 was a busy year in Canadian
politics from the Convoy protest that
crippled the nation's capital to the
conservatives choosing another new
leader there was never a dull moment our
Mercedes Stevenson is sitting down with
the Ottawa Bureau to reflect on the past
12 months and to look into their crystal
ball Mercedes
thank you so much we are here in the
west block Studio as we are every year
to talk about the biggest stories of the
Year 2022 so many unexpected stories
that change people's lives everything
from the Convoy protest that was here in
Ottawa to a land war in Europe with
Ukraine the cost of living becoming
incredibly expensive a new conservative
leader it goes on and on and that's what
we're here to talk about the stories
that really stood out to the people who
cover them we're joined by Amanda
Connolly who is our managing editor for
politics online at globalnews.ca
Mackenzie gray who is one of our
political correspondents here in Ottawa
and David Aiken of course who is our
chief political back in the studio for
the first time in two years kept us away
from we have not we had six foot
measurements last time for one person I
think in the studio this time we have
everyone back which is great Mac we
started the year out in a way that we'll
stick with I think those of us who
covered it forever the Convoy protest
you were literally in the middle of us
it uh tell me a little bit about why
that was the standout story for you
which is what you were chatting to me
about before we started part of this
panel well really it was international
news Mercedes a lot of the stuff we
cover here on Parliament Hill is
important domestic news but this took a
life of its own across the world and
became something so many people were
focusing on and rarely do we see
different levels of government not be
able to get along in the way that they
did here the city of Ottawa and the
police really bungled at the beginning
allowing the trucks to get into downtown
and that caused a lot of problems for
the three weeks leading up to the fact
the federal government needed to bring
in the emergencies act something we
spent a lot of time talking about we'll
see what Justice rule has to say about
bringing that in but the other big thing
that came from that too Mercedes was a
new conservative leader now Amanda you
of course manage all the big political
stories for Us online but one that
happened literally back to back right
after that was of course the war in
Ukraine yeah this this was a huge story
because of course the international
implications both around the world for
democracies but also for Canada too a
country that really relies on that
rules-based International order were
made so starkly clear during that
Invasion so we've seen all of that
playing out with the support from Canada
over the past year here certainly a big
question for where it goes ahead and
also what the applications will be for
other countries too facing this risk
going forward and David
um you know all of these things whether
it is local for Ottawa and us but a
national protest or an international War
they register here with our political
leaders and there was a pretty dramatic
change on the scene this year there was
and that of course is Pierre polyev the
conservative leader who yes was
associated in support of the Convoy
other leaders not so much
um we'll see how that factors into
elections in the future but I'm going to
say there's some significant things
about pauliev's election that politicos
need to pay attention to one he won by
attracting a lot of people who never got
involved in politics before and a lot of
younger people that could be very
significant as we move to an electoral
cycle two two things he did after
winning the election way behind the
scenes off the radar he's overhauled the
conservative fundraising machine even
though they raise a lot of money they
spend a lot of money to raise it so that
needed to be fixed and he's going to do
that two he's overhauled the computer
systems that conservatives use to find
new voters voters contact get out the
vote that system's busted the Liberals
have a fantastic computer system that
does that pauliev and his team know that
has to be fixed it will cost the party
tens of millions of dollars probably
take a year and a half but I'm sorry
they don't win unless that gets fixed
and we did ask Mr Collier for a year-end
interview as we have with other Federal
Party leaders his team did not get back
to us we of course would still love to
speak to him at some point when he is
willing to do the mainstream media show
is one of the big questions of course
will be what his strategy will be next
year we'll be back right after the break
to talk to our panelists about what
they're expecting in the data stories
for 2023.
[Music]
foreign
we're back with our political
correspondence and managing editor for
online politics Amanda Connolly
Mackenzie Gray from global national
David Aiken our chief political
correspondent we talked about the
biggest stories of last year now we look
forward it's always a bit of a frisky
game to play crystal ball in politics
with what we're expecting but Mack what
do you think is going to be the biggest
issue or the biggest story that seizes
Us in 2023. well I think whether or not
there's going to be an election this
deal between the NDP and the Liberals is
holding right now but we've seen a
little bit of a change from jug meet
Singh he said that it was irresponsible
to go to an election he's changing his
course now saying on Health Care in
particular that he's going to see some
movement on the budget or need to see
some movement on the budget from the
Liberals he's going to be able to
continue to support them I think Justin
Trudeau is going to stick around but
does Christian Freeland stick around
that's one thing that I'm looking for
David Aiken do you think that deal is
going to hold this is jugmeat saying
serious about this is he playing
politics because it's a good time to say
people are mad at Healthcare would he
actually pull out what do you think I
don't think so I mean I'm just going to
look at the polls I I don't think so but
yes it could happen one thing about the
federal NDP that I'm looking for in the
next year is the prevent three
provincial NDP parties I have to pay a
nickel three provincial new democrat
parties
um could have a big year there's going
to be an election in Manitoba and wob
canoe the NDP leader there good chance
of being the country's first indigenous
Premier there's going to be an election
in May and Alberta Danielle Smith and
her controversial sovereignty act up
against Rachel notley a previous Premier
you know it's a tie game there she could
win that Dave EBY the new premier in BC
it's got some very popular ideas about
how to fix the housing crisis so much so
that he's going to finish the year Well
ahead of his BC United slash BC liberal
leader so this time next year we could
be looking at three new Democrat
governments in provincial capitals BC
Alberta Manitoba some how jug meat sings
gotta harness that kind of energy to
boost his own troops but I think that
provincial capital story uh this over
the next year
I think I'm safe and predicting there's
going to be some very interesting
stories and Winnipeg and Edmonton I
think that's a pretty safe prediction
for sure Amanda what are you going to be
on the lookout for so I'm certainly not
uh in the camp that that thinks so far
again based what we're looking at that
there will be an election next year
maybe 2024 maybe push it to 2025 and the
reason for that I think is just there is
this raw anger in the country right now
particularly with younger people
generational anger over the cost of
housing over inflation cost of living
the health care crisis too that we're
seeing right now collapsing systems
across the country that anger is
dangerous if you don't have a plan to
manage it and I'm not sure right now
that any of the parties do David you've
been around the hill for a long time
three very quickly biggest challenges
for each of the major parties one for
each Breaking Through To out of their
silos all three parties do a great job
of reaching their own people their
partisan Fiora pauliev is a great
example with his social media channels
to people he likes you're not going to
win an election unless you get people
who are not inclined to look at you to
look at you the mainstream media used to
play a key role as a Commons where
people came to Gus ideas and sell their
platforms the mainstream media has less
influence now and it's more social I
think that is that is one of the big
challenges for all parties and for our
democracy going forward is having a
place where we can come and
have a comment to talk about ideas okay
super quickly Mac liberals Justin
Trudeau does he have a second act in
place to kind of reinvent himself he's
been in power for a long time he'll need
that if he wants to win the next
election preparer polly have is he the
trucker party is that what the
conservatives are right now or can they
go back to where they've centrally been
in the center center right and for drug
meat saying he has a lot of personal
popularity we see that in the polls all
the time but can he harness that into
votes would have a nice delay Amanda
last word to you I think really again
that that plan to to harness some of
this frustration in a positive way these
are we're seeing these these massive
social movements right now anger
frustration threats to democracy if you
can't funnel that into a positive course
of action and provide Solutions we're
going to be in trouble and that wraps it
up for us hopefully we'll have a
positive 2023 we'll find out but those
are our biggest stories from our very
best political correspondents who know
all the news we'll keep an eye on it for
you and we'll be back here of course see
you then
all right thanks Mercedes
[Music]
she and her sisters dominated the music
charts next remembering Anita Poynter
[Music]
Anita Poynter one of The grammy-winning
Pointer Sisters has died at the age of
74. the four-pointer sisters began
singing together more than 50 years ago
in their father's Church in Oakland
California the group won three Grammy
Awards and had 13 top 20 hits in the U.S
between 1973 and 1985. Ruth pointer is
the only one of the original singing
Sisters still alive
Team Canada is off to the quarterfinals
at the world juniors after wrapping up
the year with a win getting called up to
play in the event is a dream come true
for young hockey players Zach power has
the story of a different kind of player
who got the call weeks before the first
puck drop
play for the world juniors you have to
be good at what you do resonate with the
fans and end each game on a high note
now cue Linden Steves
his music has become nearly as much of
an extreme sport off the ice as the
players have it on the ice growing up
when I was a kid it was it was you know
we heard the classic organ song
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
and I used to play on that and my
buddies would come over and they'd be
playing mini hockey and I'd be doing the
intros and the songs for all the kids
it's quite defeat moments before Puck
jump Lyndon takes off his shoes and away
he goes
[Music]
childhood dream of hearing the classic
Tunes brought up an octave where he
incorporates tradition with the new age
of music
Zach power Global News Moncton
and that's global national for this
Sunday night and the first day of 2023
I'm Sonya sungar and Before We Say
Goodbye we leave you with an icy
tradition that requires little clothing
and lots of courage
freezing temperatures didn't stop these
Canadians from taking the plunge for
annual polar bear dips across the
country no water no problem those
without a place for a dip opted for a
run thanks for watching we'll see you
tomorrow Happy New Year
[Music]
thank you
[Music]